150 kilometer nördlich über dem
polarkreis im finnischen lappland
inmitten der weißen wälder verbirgt sich
ein kleines dorf und heiler dicken
schneedecke
eine funkelnde welt gebaut aus eis und
schnee auf gut 20.000 quadratmetern
erstreckt sich das sogenannte snow
village einer der initiatoren ist der
eiskünstler brami kutako lebe meinen
traum hier in lappland
ich bin umgeben von natur und ich kann
mit dem material arbeiten dass mich der
natur noch näher bringt es fühlt sich so
gut an diese erfahrung mit den gästen
des snow village teilen zu können
game of thrones so lautet das
diesjährige motto des snow village
motive und figuren aus der serie wurden
kunstvoll in eis gemeißelt
auch übernachten kann man hier
in einem der zehn iglo swieten verbringt
man die nacht mit einem white walker
durch die körperwärme steigt die
temperatur im iglu bei zwei gästen von
minus 5 auf etwa null grad celsius vom
veranstalter selbst wird nur eine
übernachtung empfohlen diese kostet für
zwei personen etwa 350 euro
auch steven ma und seine partnerin dina
seidel haben hier eine nacht verbracht
in schlafsäcken ausgelegt für minus 35
grad mit zusätzlichen fliesst
schlafsäcken gemütlich er nicht
aber das macht es halt auch ein
abenteuer und ich denke wenn man dann
diese kälte überlebt und dann aufwacht
nach dieser kalten nacht zu diesem vor
allem motiven
es ist schon etwas besonderes seit 17
jahren wird jedes jahr ein neues hotel
errichtet dazu kommen eiskünstler und
schnee baumeister aus aller welt und
arbeiten etwa einen monat lang am snow
village 20 millionen kilo schnee und
350.000 kilo eis werden dafür verwendet
die errichtung ist ein sehr wichtiger
teil dieser kunst der eine teil ist es
die kunst aus dem schnee zu formen der
andere die richtige beleuchtung erst so
werden die kunstwerke lebendig rami
kotaku gibt workshops in der kunst der
ice kulturen
stephen war und seine frau schnitzen mit
hilfe des künstlers aus einem eisblock
ein filigranes blatt also ich habe es
mir deutlich schwieriger vorgestellt
also ich hätte nicht gedacht dass man
innerhalb einer stunde sollen bleibt
machen kann mit so viel details kann
leicht brechen
doch kleine feder lassen sich leicht
beheben durch körperwärme werden
bruchstücke durch die schmelze blick
einfach wieder angeklebt
also man betrachtet die auf jeden fall
mit ganz anderen augen
einfach weil man mehr wissen hat die die
geräte auch mal gesehen hat selbst zähle
hand geführt hatte selbst getestet hat
und allein dadurch betrachtet man
natürlich anderen kunstwerke dann auch
ganz anders beim drachen aus zwölf
tonnen eis wurde jeder zahn einzeln
angefertigt und angeklebt er schmückt
die eisbahn besucher aus aller welt
kommen in das snow village und können
hier getränke in kleinen gläsern aus eis
genießen
sozusagen in rock auch heiraten kann man
bei minusgraden in der eiskapelle geben
sich immer wieder brautpaare das jawort
wer hunger hat geht ins iglu restaurant
erinnere durchmesser beträgt 16 meter
bei 200 quadratmeter fläche
wenn einem kalt ist ist das ein guter
platz um sich aufzuwärmen
bei jeder weiß wenn du was im magen hast
fühlst du dich gleich viel wärmer die
essens erfahrungen sind speziell es
fühlt sich wirklich merkwürdig an wenn
einem so kalt ist und dinge zu halten
die so kalt sind
man muss ja die handschuhe anbehalten
und damit etwas heißes schnell essen
weil es sonst so schnell kalt wird
ich habe hier schon einen abdruck mit
meiner heißen schokolade gemacht wollte
ich gar nicht und markt ziemlich schnell
fest wenn man seine hände zu lange auf
stützt 1 kunst ist auch zum anfassen
darf
sie lässt sich unmittelbar erfahren bis
zum april
dann beginnt das dorf zu schmelzen
ehrlich gesagt es ist schon ein bisschen
traurig wenn alles wegschmilzt aber
gleichzeitig ist es so faszinierend mit
diesem material zu arbeiten
die kunst die duh kreiert existiert nur
eine kurze zeit bevor sie verschwindet
du kannst alles hier also nur diesen
einen winter erleben
im nächsten winter wieder kommst kannst
du diese kunstwerke nicht mehr sehen
die künstler haben schon jetzt ideen für
das kommende jahr aber bis zum frühling
werden noch tausende besucher die
aktuellen kunstwerke bewundern können